in the last video when we talked about
secondary structure we talked about
Alpha Ulysses in this video we're going
to talk about beta pleated sheets and
sort of focus on them they are still
part of secondary structure so we're
still talking about hydrogen bonds
between the backbone of a polypeptide
chain let's talk about a few details of
beta pleated sheets sort of what they
are or what's important about them and
how we can understand them
so beta pleated sheets are really just
that so the the polypeptide chain ends
up sort of making these little they make
little sheets which sounds kind of you
know straightforward and weird when I
say that but we end up making these
little sheets that have bends in them
like this right and then imagine the
polypeptide chain being like that and
it'll be right next to another sheet
like this so this might not make sense
just yet
but what I kind of wanted to jot down
about beta pleated sheets is that
they're basically just polypeptide I
abbreviate polypeptide as PPT
polypeptide chains okay that sort of are
adjacent to each other okay and um
specifically about this and they
actually held together via the hydrogen
bonds so if this is one beta pleated
sheet one right next to it
right these these are going to be held
together you know with a hydrogen bonds
between the backbone okay so these
little green things here are H bonds
between the backbone okay
so specifically between the backbone
they're between the carbonyl oxygens and
the and the amide nitrogen okay so now
these these chains can run either
parallel or antiparallel and I'll kind
of explain that
in just a moment by drawing it out
another thing I wanted to mention about
about beta pleated sheets is that when
we have these these polypeptide chains
running like this the R groups the R
groups alternate pointing above the
plane and below the plane again I'm
going to depict all this there's want to
jot down these notes before I actually
begin drawing them out they alternate
pointing up and down or above and below
the sheet okay the actual alpha carbons
each of these little bends here these
little bends that we call the pleats the
pleats come from our are you know that
Bend there is the alpha carbon and I'll
draw that out in just a moment okay so
one thing to sort of understand
particularly and how you know the beta
pleated sheets are a little bit
different than alpha helixes is that
they're H bonds okay are perpendicular
to the direction of the polypeptide
again I'm abbreviating polypeptide is
PPT so remember this is actually
opposite of the Alpha helix which had
the the hydrogen bonds were parallel to
the axis of the helix so I want to
explain this now draw this out and make
a little bit more sense um so let me
show you how this would sort of work if
we have a polypeptide chain that looks
like this let's
all this like this bear with me for this
is this might be a little bit tough okay
let's say we have an amino group here
okay and this would be the Alpha carbon
here this would be carbon Neil
now I haven't drawn amino acids like
this for you just yet
but you can imagine this being the amino
group and then this here this alpha
carbon will have an R group and a
hydrogen here and then next you know
that this this here would be the you
know what was the carboxyl group
connected to the next amino group so
then this here is also an alpha carbon
with its own R group pointing down and
then a hydrogen as well okay and this
here would be the carboxyl terminus okay
let's just make this really really short
sort of chain okay where this is the
n-terminus and this is the c terminus so
imagine this being a short sort of
polypeptide chain this could run right
next to another polypeptide chain that
looks kind of like this and I'm actually
going to draw this a little bit I'm
going to draw from the inside first here
just to be be as thorough as possible
okay you'll see why I'm drawing it like
this just a moment okay and here's the
carbonyl group then this is the offic or
the next alpha carbon so this has an R
group here and a hydrogen here and then
we have another carbonyl group might
hydrogen mmm another R group up here hey
cheer maybe already some of you are so
kind of seeing how this whole how these
little notes here sort of play it you
know play into what I'm drawing here now
let me kind of point it out specifically
what I'm trying to get at
so I mentioned over here that the
peptide chains are adjacent to each
other so I'm sure you can see that this
is this
one polypeptide chain this is another
and they're right next to each other now
this could go on and on and on and
further and look at this one I'm just
drawing it here just has a short sort of
representative model now I mentioned
that the hydrogen bonds are
perpendicular to the direction of the
chains so the H bond would actually be
just like this right here in between the
carbonyl oxygen and the a might hydrogen
so there would be that that there now
that's the only one I'm drawing here is
because I don't have a much room but
then you can imagine that if this
continued on we keep having a bunch of
different H bonds here and here and
there but essentially what I wanted to
get at is to sort of explain is that if
you have a polypeptide chain next to
another one and they run adjacent to
each other they can run parallel or
antiparallel and I'll get to the
difference between that in just a moment
but the point is that these the hydrogen
bonds that will actually be holding
those those changed together are
perpendicular to the overall direction
of the you know the two the two strands
which brings me to this idea of parallel
or antiparallel so notice that this this
chain is running n to C right and this
chain is also running and C they're both
running in the same direction so that
would be considered parallel okay
because both of them are running in the
same direction and to see now we could
have one going n to C in one going C to
N or that would be considered anti
parallel so if you have if you have you
know n to C run running right next to n
to C that would be considered parallel
whereas anti parallel or antiparallel
would be if you had one polypeptide
chain running and to C and another one
running the opposite way okay this would
be anti parallel okay so I mentioned
that the R groups would be alternating
pointing up and pointing down above and
below the plane so what am I getting at
there well that's just this right here
so notice that in this chain we have on
our group going pointing up and then the
next one the R group is 20
out here we got up and then down up and
then the next one would be down but the
point is that they would alternate there
so I put a little star in purple here so
you understand it that this this the
circling of these these are groups in
purple is sort of explaining this point
here okay and the pleats of the off of
carbons and I'm sure you can see that so
a point I'll point that out with I don't
know let's see it's too it's too orange
or or whatever this color is so the
pleats are the Alpha carbon so here's an
alpha carbon where the R group is
attached as is this one those little
bends right are the actual alpha carbons
there and there okay and the H bonds are
perpendicular to the direction of the
polypeptide chain so so what is what is
really going on with this whole whole
idea we can imagine this let me sort of
depict this one more way if we have a
sheet running and to see like this right
this is the beginning of a beta pleated
sheet right then for whatever reason
this is a theme that we would see in you
know some sort of globular protein or
just any protein but let's say at a
certain point it just sort of stops and
then we have like this long string of
amino acids that doesn't really have any
sort of theme to it right but then as it
comes back then we have a beta pleated
sheet right and then it just sort of you
know goes off and does its own thing
again this kind of looks crazy
but then as it comes back we got more
pleats right so what I'm trying to get
at really is that first of all this is
the n-terminus this end here
I made a c-terminus okay let me make
that a little bit neater now this
obviously looks ridiculous and crazy but
I really only want you to pay attention
to this inside portion here of these
sheets right this here is what we're
trying to talk about we're talking about
beta pleated sheets that there is a
theme a secondary structure theme so
here we have this chain going and
see right so this here this portion of
the pleat here on top would be going n
to see right where this this last end
here would be the C terminus right that
we keep going keep going keep going and
then going here right after all these
crazy turns we end up coming back so
this is here the beginning of the n
right and we're going all the way to the
C at the end here right and then we go
and do some more crazy turns and we come
back and we go and to C again right so
these are these these beta pleated sheet
or beta pleated sheets are running anti
parallel now that's a little bit crazy
but the Y idea is that these these
themes can be present in proteins that
that you know have these all kinds of
crazy for the directions the cool thing
about our facilities are already put a
sheet so that you might find beta if you
choose in one area of a protein may be
alpha helix C's elsewhere the point is
that there are themes one more thing I
want to mention specifically about beta
pleated sheets is that they can be they
can exist between polypeptide chains of
you know either a single polypeptide
chain in this case right I didn't really
pick up the pen as I was drawing all
these different white lines that look
kind of crazy but this is all one
polypeptide so the hot this thing right
it's just one polypeptide beta pleated
sheets can exist between different
polypeptide chains so let's say I have
you know this and then I draw another
polypeptide chain that's actually not
connected as part of this long one here
and then I start maybe I should put that
put that at a different color if I draw
another polypeptide chain that you know
starts off crazy like this and then this
being the end terminus and then you know
it continues on it is somehow gets next
to this polypeptide chain right then we
have quaternary structure right because
then we have another a second
polypeptide chain and then maybe it
comes back again who knows right but the
point is this can be some core of crazy
protein with an enter with a carboxy
terminus right what the point is this
theme here still exists I know this is
crazy messy but to me that's biochem for
you I suppose but hopefully that was a
little bit helpful in terms of kind of
visualizing what a beta pleated sheet is
I definitely encourage you to look up
these you know baby photos a diagram
these on you know on google or a
textbook or whatever it is that you're
using the study but anyways those hold
up I hope that was helpful and I'll see
in the next video